hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american sci-fi thriller film
called time lapse
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts as we see a painter
named finn trying to paint a canvas in
his apartment
he lives in the same apartment with his
girlfriend cali and his best friend
jasper finn is also the manager of that
apartment complex
while jasper is a gambling addict that
day
finn meets the apartment security guard
big joe who he invites to a house party
on the next day
soon after their landlord calls to
inform them that one of the tenants
called mr b
is two months late to pay his rent so
kelly goes to check on mr b she knocks
on the door
but no one answers there is also a pile
of newspapers in front of the door
suggesting that he has not come out for
a long time kelly uses spare keys to go
inside
cut to finn's room finn and jasper are
talking when
cali barges in and takes them to mr b's
apartment the three of them go in to see
a wall full of polaroid pictures of
their living room
mr b had been taking pictures of them
through their living room window
jasper thinks he was spying on them but
there are empty pictures of the room as
well
moreover some of the pictures from the
collection are missing
finn turns around and sees a huge
machine in the same room
it looks like a massive camera pointed
directly at their living room window
a polaroid picture hands from it we see
that the coat rack from their living
room is knocked over in it
they figure that the pictures on the
walls are taken from this camera
later they are in their apartment
talking when cali suddenly knocks over
the rack
the group matches the picture with the
look of their living room and it is a
perfect match
the group realizes that the camera takes
photos apparently 24 hours in the future
suddenly the camera takes a picture on
its own they look at it to see it as the
picture of the next day when they were
going to have a house party
the three of them are in shock jasper
still doesn't believe that the camera
takes pictures of the future
kelly finds mr b's journal which says
that he has seen his death through the
camera
so he planned to disobey the cardinal
rule of time and causality
finn examines the pictures and finds
that all of them are taken at exactly 8
pm
however the wall has some pictures taken
during the day time
strangely some of the pictures from the
wall are missing
then the group goes to mr b's storage
unit and finds his dead
body there his face looks burnt and
rotten but his clothes are fine
jasper thinks that he died because he
disobeyed the cardinal rule
they are now back in their apartment
when jasper suggests they use the camera
to gamble
finn is doubtful of the idea but cali
supports it
that night they have a house party
jasper and cali dance with the guests
while finn goes to mr b's place and
takes a picture exactly at 8pm
he compares the polaroid picture with
the picture he took and it is exactly
the same just then a picture comes out
from the camera
in the picture he sees the three of them
posing for the camera a paper with the
gambling results as pasted on the window
the following day finn is still doubtful
of the idea that cali suggests that if
they do not do what the picture says
they would be breaking the cardinal rule
they can end up like mr b as well
so callie starts watering mr b's plants
and taking his newspaper to make it seem
like he is still in his house
finn looks at the canvas in the picture
and paints without having to brainstorm
any ideas
meanwhile jasper tapes the gambling
results to the window every day
several days go by and the group earns a
lot of money through it as they cover up
mr b's disappearance
however a week later they receive a
picture in which jasper and cali are
kissing in the background
while finn paints in front of them finn
is disturbed by the picture but they
have to do what it says to follow the
cardinal rule
so that night jasper and cali kiss as
finn paints
but the actual kiss goes on too long
causing finn to get angry and jealous
he goes to mr b's place and the new
picture is already there
in it they see jasper's gambling bookie
ivan
sitting in their living room the group
is shocked because ivan is a violent
criminal
the following day jasper is very nervous
he stays on the couch
waiting for ivan as cali and finn leave
soon after
ivan comes to visit he is suspicious of
jasper's recent wins
so he threatens jasper to tell him his
secret jasper tells him that ivan can
ride on his gambles and leave them alone
just then callie and finn arrive with
the next day's picture
in the picture cali is nude posing for
finn's painting as jasper silhouette
spies on them through the mirror
ivan gets a look at the picture too and
then he leaves
cut to the next day finn and callie get
ready to paint
cali poses as finn paints her but
exactly at eight they see ivan outside
the window
turns out that the silhouette from the
picture was actually ivan
he and his goon marcus threaten the
group and find out about the camera
they make a deal now the group has to
pose for the photos with gambling
results every day for ivan to make bets
on
he wants to profit off the camera
himself the group does as ivan says
they provide him with the gambling
results for a few days
when suddenly one day finn notices that
the next day's picture has a weird
painting on it
this photo shows a hastily made skull
and crossbones on the canvas
it is not finn's usual style of painting
the group thinks that the future finn is
trying to warn them of something
so jasper is very nervous the next day
he hides several weapons around the
living room in case someone attacks them
he practices stabbing with his knife
that evening
finn runs into big joe at the gate who
has just gotten a job as a police
officer
but as they talk marcus spies on them
from his car
joe gives finn his card he is a police
officer now
when finn comes back to the room he
tells jasper what has happened
some time later ivan and marcus arrive
they're suspicious of big joe
they find the card of the police and
question the trio about their connection
with joe
they threatened to kill all three of
them but jasper lies to him that he has
seen tomorrow's picture which is ivan
being killed by marcus in it
this makes ivan suspicious of marcus so
he goes to mr b's apartment to look at
the picture and confirm it himself
meanwhile jasper stabs marcus as he had
practiced
when ivan comes back he sees marcus dead
and jasper attacks him with a bat and
kills him as well
the group hides the bodies in mr b's
storage unit they see that the new
picture is actually a picture of jasper
sitting on the couch with a pile of
money in front of him
they take all of ivan's gambling money
so now they have millions of dollars
that night finn suggests that they split
the money and get out of the country
but the other two are against the idea
at night someone knocks on their door
it is mr b's friend and colleague dr
heideker who is looking for mr b
however jasper can't keep their stories
straight about mr b
so dr heidecker levels a gun at them and
forces them to confess
mr b had written her a letter before his
death in the letter he had told her
about the camera being successful and
about his death
he had also sent her a picture it is a
picture of the group's living room with
mr b's hat in the background and blood
splattered on the windows
he has seen the picture and thought that
he was about to die so he locked himself
in his storage unit
they take her to the unit and heidecker
realizes that mr b did not die because
of the rule of cardinals
he reached for the shelves in the
cabinet and died because a chemical
poured over him
it was just an accident heidecker also
tells them that the picture is of
tomorrow
finn and jasper are surprised to know
that the camera can click pictures more
than 24 hours in advance
but currently it is set to 24 hours in
the future and the timer is always set
at 8 pm
knowing that heidecker is of no real use
to them jasper kills her with ivan's gun
they hide her body there and come back
to their place
finn blames jasper for killing an
innocent woman so he has now decided to
move out of their place
at 8 p.m jasper takes the picture with a
pile of money
while callie goes to look at the picture
for tomorrow finn comes out with his
suitcase packed in order to leave the
place and flee
he goes to mr b's place where jasper and
callie are sitting in distress
the next day's picture is a picture of
cali and jasper having sex as finn
sleeps on the couch behind
finn is furious to see this cali runs
away from there
then finn shows jasper an engagement
ring he had bought for cali a long time
ago
as finn talks jasper hits him on the
head making him go unconscious
he drags finn to the storage unit and
ties him there
jasper wants to do what the camera says
making sure the photo happens
no matter what jasper then goes to the
apartment and wait until tomorrow at 8
pm
the next morning finn wakes up at the
storage unit he burns the ropes and
frees himself
he takes the keys from mr b's pockets
and escapes from the storage unit
he then takes a bucket of water and goes
to mr b's place
he calls jasper from there and threatens
to pour water on the camera
finn wants jasper to let cali and him go
away and move to some other place
jasper calls callie outside and points
his gun at her
he tries to threaten finn to kill callie
but it doesn't work
finn that asks callie to look into
jasper's pocket where she finds the ring
she is delighted then she takes jasper's
gun and opens the door for finn
all three of them are in the apartment
now finn tells cali to pack her clothes
they plan to flee as soon as possible
but as cali goes to do that
jasper attacks finn he is almost about
to kill finn when suddenly
callie appears from behind and kills
jasper to save finn
then callie goes into the kitchen to get
thin eyes for his injuries
but when finn goes in to check he sees
her going through a different drawer
kelly makes an excuse but finn senses
something wrong
she takes him to their room and leaves
him there with the ice however
finn comes to check and he sees cali
posing for the camera
she has two notes pasted on the window
finn is surprised to see the camera take
a picture because it is 8 am
this whole time he thought the camera
only takes pictures at 8 p.m
he asks kelly about it and this is where
everything is revealed
before the events in the film finn and
callie had been having problems with
their relationship
finn had been acting distant and cali
was not feeling the love
so callie slept with jasper what they
didn't realize
is that mr b's time camera had been
taking pictures of their naughtiness the
whole time
when callie went into mr b's apartment
for the first time she saw the machine
in the photos
she also saw the pictures that had been
taken during her naughtiness with jasper
this includes the photo of him having
sex she wanted to hide this
so she removed those pictures she also
figured that the machine was set to take
pictures at 8am and 8pm
but callie kept the 8am part a secret
because she saw a picture of herself
from the following morning standing with
notes that read
not coat stand over hide last week's
daytime photos
so she decided to hide that 8am
information to pass instructions
secretly to herself
these instructions are to help her get
finn back close to her all this time
when she went to water the plants at mr
b's place in the morning
she always took the 8 a.m picture with a
message from her future self
one morning kelly got the 8 am picture
that reed kissed jasper for too long
so when 8 pm arrived she followed that
instruction and stretched out the kiss
she was rewarded with finn getting
jealous all she wants is that for him to
fight for their relationship
the day before callie had already
received a message at 8am asking herself
to swap out that day's picture
with the sex photo so she followed the
instructions
the purpose was to make finn jealous and
fight for their relationship
and it turned out to be successful today
he fought for their relationship harder
than she has ever seen
after cali's truth is revealed finn
rejects her
he decides that all of this is wrong and
he needs to destroy the machine
but callie shoots him first and kills
him this creates the blood splatter on
the window
just like in heideker's photo she wants
to put up a message for 8 p.m saying
don't get caught at the window
she thinks that if she sends herself a
message in the window when the photo is
taken
it will send a message to herself 24
hours ago preventing these events from
happening
just as she's waiting for the camera to
go out joe the cop shows up and asks her
who opened the door
he finds people dead in the hall so he
takes callie away
kelly leaves peacefully confident that
all this will be over once her past self
sees the message she has taped and the
timeline will reset
joe leads callie out of the house to
arrest her but just then the note she
left falls off the window
cali tries to run back to stick the
message back on but joe drags her away
the camera takes its 8 pm snap and
before the image develops
it cuts to black and the movie ends cali
cannot change the event because this is
predestination
the causal loop has already occurred it
can't be changed
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching